thank you very much
my assignment began in a strange way I
was asked to 9 months ago if I would had
a thought about what would be a good
novel for a book club to read and I said
all the king's man then months later I
got a communication ask me when would be
a good time to come and give my talk and
so you can imagine no I did over
Christmas was to reread a book that I
had read in the summer of 1957 and had
been influenced by it but had forgotten
a lot a long how thoughtful how woven
with literary and philosophical all's
political elements and so what could I
do today it seemed to me there were
three aspects of the novel that was
clear
one is that it is in some sense a
treatise on issues of the human
condition
second is has at least one and probably
several political stories protocol
elements woven together and and and
third it's a series of lessons if you
read you'll see the authors put things
right out there for you as a way of a
lesson here or a lesson there and so
taking those three elements I said to
myself well what what can I talk about
that would be sensible for me a scholar
of political science and not literature
and the answer was I would give you the
lessons that I think I have and I would
share with you as lessons for today that
the novel brought to mind or stimulated
thus this is not an exegetical talk on
the author or the work itself but rather
some thoughts about what I think the
book conveys having said that these
three elements come out as four lessons
for today the four lessons are pretty
simple the first is that history real
history enriches literature and that you
can see with Huey Long being the major
character
that the novel is a taking advantage of
the second is that the human condition
is what you make of it the third is
politics is dirty and the fourth is that
good comes from bad
maybe so those are the four themes that
I'm going to try and offer to you by way
of lessons in the novel or that maybe we
can read out of the novel with our own
reactions to it
what about history enriches literature
well clearly the life of Huey Long and
the life of Robert Penn Warren which
overlapped a fair amount and shared
certain characteristics in terms of a
concern for the south and a concern for
people who are being put under all kinds
of unfair conditions in the south
overlapped totally Huey Long's life as
this meteoric politician who is able to
be the political machine and then turn
into a very crafty and even more
ruthless politician and the people he's
displaced with high aspirations and
apparently enormous charisma so that he
quickly goes from being a governor to a
senator from a senator to planning to
run against Roosevelt the Democratic
primary in 1936 and he announces that
just a month before his assassination
the assassination which is one of the
more accurate points and in the novel
where history is really drawn upon to
put the parameters down for for what
happens and Huey Long not only was all
those things through the book and thus
makes the book real there's a kind of a
reality check of verisimilitude that
that comes from using that historical
story but it also I think picks up
certain themes how this Willie Starks
career gets started well the book is a
little different in the real world but
the fire escape on the schoolhouse
and people are killed and suddenly this
relatively innocent well-meaning
politician becomes ingrained in the
hearts at least to the people in Mason
City in northern Louisiana which is the
more marginalized or part of Louisiana
and what happened to Huey Long was there
was a flood in 1927 which devastated
partly white design when people
dynamited some of the dykes the poorest
aren't parts of New Orleans and when the
federal government failed to respond and
when the local banks and oil companies
and so on had no interest in helping out
these folks who we along took up their
cause and parlayed that into winning the
governorship and winning it by more
votes than that anyone had ever won
before and of course you know what
Sudama needs a Democratic primary in one
but people actually turned out and voted
for him and so this was a fairly
powerful historical event and I think
that's in the back of the mind of our
Penn Warren as he's crafting his novel
well I'll say no more right now I had a
number of excerpts maybe I'll just give
you a couple of excerpts from the life
of Huey Long it suggests why I think the
use of him as a historical backdrop for
the novel is is so compelling when he
was successful running for the
governorship
he said his focus was going to be on
education and on putting things in place
and what we now call physical public
goods like roads there were 331 miles of
paved road in Louisiana when he was
elected he authored 3,000 more within a
short time he did put his emphasis on
education and he wanted to help poor
children have access to textbooks who
say couldn't even get for their school
system but of course to have them go
into the say the Catholic schools was
violating there were all sorts of
boundary conditions that which were
difficult and what he did was two things
he taxed
oil companies and that he gave away the
schoolbooks not to the schools but to
the children and thus was able to get
around some of these laws and
constraints and it was that kind of
imagination and and kind of bigger and
you got this sense in the novel that
that Willie Stark is really motivated
he's really the practical person who's
going to push people around till he gets
done the good things he wants to do it
you can see this I think also therefore
in the life of the real Huey Long there
are other things you may want to ask
about Huey Long's aspirations and
assassination but I should move along so
I just would underline that the key
point that by drawing on the real
history of Louisiana politics and the
real nature of the kind of class
struggle that was going on there which
was an important forewarn and other
people riding in that era but making it
kind of vital to the real life I think
enriches the nominal and makes the novel
have a kind of reality check for us
today this isn't just myth this is
elements of reality here the second the
human condition is what you make it
there are a lot of talk philosophical
talk in this novel as you those of you
who had a chance of working away all the
way through it now and you get things
like ideal I'm an idealist with the
capital I Jack burden this is an
idealist and he's philosophizing about
what does it all mean how do we know and
do I have to know history and what is
truth and how do I get it truth and I've
actually Xerox dozens of pages here that
I could read to you about these theses
that I'm not going to but but there's
also between these the two main
characters the two stories were told at
the end of the novel the story of Willie
Stark the politician and the story of
Jack burden who's involved in politics
he's also involved in figuring out how
to live and solve his own life and deal
with his past we have a wonderful set of
notions about what is the
in addition remember Willie starts out
innocent thinking that just through
articulating what's true people will
rally around and do things in the course
he's utterly devastated in that first
election and then he set up the run for
governor and then in the midst of that
he discovers that he's been set up as a
way to split the vote and keep the kind
of machine politics that's biased
towards the oil and gas and banking
other interests in power and he still
goes on but now he's determined he's a
very strong determined personality what
does he believe after this sort of early
I call his first epiphany
he believes that man we now say people I
suppose is is conceived in sin and born
in corruption and thus you know the
human condition is mired in this
original sin if you like and that's the
way it is when you know that you can
turn it and use it against your enemies
for good and so he's got this
understanding of the human condition
he's got energy and he's going to use it
and by using it he is going to overcome
the necessary
maybe issues of is he a moral person
he's a good person because he's doing
this for good the long run he can he can
rationalize bringing in tiny Duffy as
his assistant he can rationalize
manipulating people in the machine to
come to his side and in some ways this
is Huey Long but it it's in the novel
clearly a philosophical point of view
about the nature of the human condition
and that's the that's like the thesis in
some ways of a dialogue Jack burden on
the other hand is this kind of more
agnostic recorder of history who's
outside of history because as he says
one of the early passages you may recall
there driving along and he looks out and
he sees these cows and he says what's
going on in the brain of those cows and
what they're thinking of this car going
by with me in it and well whatever
they're thinking is all in my brain in
any event so it doesn't matter what
they're thinking because there's almost
in my brain so he really is he said in
college I learned how to be
I know it was Hegel or Schopenhauer he
read somebody and became this kind of
disjunctive idealist and that's a
position that leads him to not take
action not take a moral position to
always be skeptical to step outside of
things so he's obviously has great
capacity as human being we know he has
these these these resources but but
they're always disengaged from some sort
of end purpose other than a kind of in
the novel particularly a loyalty to
Willie because he respects what he saw
at him in his early years and he also
respects what he's trying to do as a
political project and there's he's alias
from his own heritage because he
represents of course those landed
traditional elite interests burdens
landing and the folks who lived there
he carries a real burden of that kind of
X now exploitative social class so those
are two kind of statements about the
human condition neither these people it
seems in the represents you might say a
clear definition heller of the human
condition they're making arguments in
their lives about it there are some
people who novels however who are like
they stepped out of a morality play
think of for example Adams Stanton
animist Anton only wants to do good
practically 24 hours a day to help
people through health through doing all
these things he's such a pure noble
person I mean you can think about you
know he's not only celibate as far as
you can tell but he's just dedicated and
he's honest and he always tells the
truth he's a good friend and of course
he ends up being a murderer and being
killed and so you think well he saw blew
his top at the end what he thought he
was what he was somehow put in a
position to be defined as getting a
reward the head of this hospital center
because he pimped his sister to the
governor
and that just blows his mind that he
would be seen as by others is so morally
so he is in some sense this ideally good
person but even he can't quite deal with
the kind of slander that people engaging
in politics refraining who people are
are there any people who were purely
evil if he's purely good well I think so
I think tiny Duffy
I mean tiny Duffy is really a son of a
[ __ ] and while there's nothing quite
there that says that does tiny doesn't
talk very much I think you can see that
in the way Jack burden one of the
crucial points in his life says and I
could be like tiny by putting him down
just the way tiny maneuvered the murder
of Willy and I won't do that but but in
seeing that you really get a sense that
I think Connie is an unredeemable but
now what's that mean for us what is the
human condition not one extreme you
could be a tiny Duffy if you wanted to
you the other extreme you could be a I
guess the Adam Stanton and you could be
somewhere in between like his sister
Anne who's or Jack or Willie or some of
the other characters I I don't know
maybe Lucy Stark is relatively pure too
and in some ways of course she is the
most forgiving and and consolidating and
in the end gets a reward to become a
grandmother but what's all this say
about the nature of the human condition
I think what it says again I have all
these things that I think will only be
inefficient if I try and do what I had
planned to do which was to quote them
for you it is to is to say that the
author is struggling to say to us you
know the nature of being human is a
problem it's an argument it's a struggle
and that the answer is in the dynamics
and send the discovery it's in the
redefinition of the self as I suggested
the human condition is what
make of it Willie for example is this
relatively energetic hard-working person
and then he has this epiphany of how
he's being manipulated and used and he's
gonna get back at the folks by using all
their tactics and making it twice as
hard and he's successful and he becomes
governor and it isn't one of the blurbs
for this movie that's coming out
sometime this year we think is that Lord
Acton's aphorism power corrupts or
absolute power corrupts absolutely I
think that's much too simple it's not
that power corrupts Willie but it's
rather to get power you have to be
willing to use corrupt means and he is
willing to because using getting power
so he can do good it justifies it and he
believes that and even to the point
where after this epiphany he becomes
this very powerful politician still able
to bring in a cadre of people Tony
Delfin reminding what really all is
Sadie Burke one of his the three women
who love him genuinely in the novel he
experiences that of course he he has a a
second kind of epiphany when he realized
he's been using his son to advance his
own kind of self-worth and political
career and his son partly because of his
pushing has this terrible tragedy on the
football field and suddenly Willie has
to face the fact that he's responsible
and that weekend you recall what does he
do he breaks off his affair with Ann who
was going to be his wife when he goes to
Washington as a senator and Maivia
president he tells Sadie who loves him
very much and has been very powerful a
kind of the Karl Rove of his efforts may
be nicer but many day uh he's done with
her too
he's going back to Lucy the woman who
originally gave her love and helped him
as a teacher even though she was older
he no longer kind of romantically
important to him he's going back to her
and of course that's what then in this
corrupt situation
loosens the forces that killing right
because then Sadie tells tiny Daffy hey
you know she's angry as heck and Dolphy
has just been way because the other
thing apart is his redemption after this
is he's gonna stop doing corrupt things
and so he's gonna undo the contract for
the hospital which was part of something
that would bring in votes and and beat
the other machine people it would sort
of lock his election in and he's going
to undo that too and that's what I need
of course was going to make this the
Bucks on the side so I don't know we
have anything equivalent in Iraq today
in terms of you know government
contracts they're worth a lot of side
payments to the people who get them but
clearly this is a phenomenon in politics
in which if you cross someone somewhere
along the line you may get them coming
right back at you and so was in a couple
of days he's being killed thanks to so
there's something here about in his
second epiphany I would call it he can't
continue to behave in this
unconscionable way he's gonna return to
his original principles but he can't
succeed in politics mainly my third
point politics is dirty that is you know
once you giant trying and get out of
that pattern there's so many people who
are in it will now be your enemies far
more than before so but that's a
complicated notion about the conditions
Jack the other hand is really even more
complicated because he he has this
troubled childhood kind of a loveless
situation as he grows up in a household
he doesn't fully understand he goes off
he's got to get PhD in history as you
recall rather than law school and then
he there's a story inside story you talk
about but but clearly in the process of
not finishing and he has this first of
his great big sleeps he recall and out
of that big sleep he then becomes a
journalist and then eats Willie and get
started on this major part of the novel
in which he's telling the story is the
crime because everything we hear of
course is through his mind and through
his what he chooses to tell us and how
he tells us what's important
well then he has a shock when his
childhood romantic figure and Stanton
says that she's going out with his hero
governor's Stark and he goes off to
California where else would you go and
as the second Big Sleep each time
enriched with cigarettes and alcohol
it's a strange how we don't use those as
props anymore but their thickens you
know in the novel anyway out of that he
so he realized that he really loves and
Stanton in a kind of pure unreservedly
isn't going to back and be angry at her
for having a having affair or being
committed to the governor he's just as
he loves her he now he knows that he
solves a problem for him and it somehow
unburdens him and then the Third Kind of
not so much a big sleep it's only a
period of thinking through things after
Willie is dead and that those months in
which he's out of a job at he's living
off his newly discovered father a little
bit of income and so on he comes around
to understanding a few things one of
which is he says if you want to go
forward in life you have to understand
and respect and accept in your past so
you have to know and accept your past in
order to go forward and that that comes
for the end of the moment I think that's
a kind of it he said I was no longer
this agnostic in fact really atheist
remember he he invents the theory of the
great twitch the frog leg is electrified
and he said they don't know that I
believe in it great twitch which is you
know the God so there's this theological
theme that he solved he has a clearly a
theological argument and in that
argument
it's a godless world it's a mechanical
world so it's a it's a world which is in
his brain and maybe not outside of it
even is outside it's all phony in some
ways and then he says at the very end
after this third kind of refresh rest
of who he was and of course new
information about his mother
relationship of his mother to his real
father and so on
very interesting complicated he accepts
all this and he's now able to make his
own path through his own things which is
of course leading burdens landing do
nothing but you get a sense at the end
of the novel that he's now in command in
his life he's actually now found and who
says to him if you hadn't there's a
great passage she basically he says what
I just said to you about if you don't
look back and accept your past you can't
go forward and she said if you hadn't
said that I couldn't get along with you
come together again but now that you've
said it now that you know that it's
possible and so there's a wonderful
imagery there of the two people
struggling for 20 years or so from 15 to
35 or so they finally get together at
the end of the novel and with the sense
that they can lead their physical houses
of great wealth on the the Seacoast and
so on and and go often in the direction
so in that sense there's a very that you
know the in the inside the the just
jacket there's this phrase while hope is
alive from the Divine Comedy and I think
that's you know that by accident there
to suggest at the end that's hope is
alive while you still are struggling
with this human condition and when you
keep strung with it and then accept it
so that's that's an argument about the
human condition I wanted to share with
you
politics is dirty well what more is
there to be said QED I mean maybe
there's this this comes out in a very
ways I said the tiny Duffy is of course
the epitome of this sort of claim one of
the things that happens at the time that
that Willie Stark son Tom is in the
hospital after this injury is that all
the clack
these sort of would be political friends
the County chairmen are all showing up
in the governor's mansion with flowers
and Jack comes in who notices that of
course they all have these wonderful
bouquets of flowers and he brings his
little paragraph so he may remember it
where he says you know all those flowers
came from so-and-so's flower shop just
as it every funeral of a policeman they
go to that flower shop and they don't
learn the cheap flowers they order the
expensive flowers and that woman sends
the list of who gave you know how much
for flowers to tiny Duffy along with his
cut so every policeman's funeral is
accompanied with his transfer to the
corrupt politician and even of course
all these flowers then gracing the
governor's office are a symbol of the
kind of corruption that he's mired in
and which the people he's brought in to
help him be tough with his opponents are
mired in so yeah politics in that sense
that's that's an imagery of politics is
dirty there are other aspects like I
could point to but I think that gives
you enough that the argument of one
point of a governor start really really
saying about the judge and and and he
says is more generally everybody's got
something on just have to dig it out
right we just have to get you know the
special counsel to go after them and you
will dig up something and it'll make a
good story and we'll arm them enabled
therefore be compliant with what we want
so we'll go after judge Irwin because
he'll have something on the jack of
course things that you know this is the
man who's the hero not his father at
that point wasn't no but was a copy of
uncle er honorable figure and and Irwin
is a good man you know I didn't mention
him earlier as the morality play
personification of good but he could be
that he so he was a candidate for that
and yet we find out let's see as Jack
under covers this stuff the judge before
he was a judge was Attorney General
while he was Attorney General he decided
a case and
favor of some utilities were very
powerful and helpful and he got a big
job with them and left government to get
enough money to save his house because
he was in a loser's house of course he
had an earlier scheme to save his house
which was he married a second time a
woman who was wealthy but it turned out
she was poor so that this guy seems
pretty fluffy and of course he was
faithful to his second wife
I guess except he was a father of jacks
so how did he that happen that Jack's
mother and he I mean you know think
about Judge earliness see maybe not that
uncle aw personality but he was in
politics and Jack realizes that in some
sense it's dirty but there could be good
people and at the very end he said and
the judge was a good man
so he he perceives the possibility of
being in politics and being good even
though it is in fact inevitably somehow
tied up with corruption so the first
argument of Willie's talk about
corruption and sin and the human nature
turned into politics which means all
politics of 30 there may be this last
spot there's one other exchange in the
in the novel and that's that you can't
get anything good until you had
something bad or that good comes from
bad already mentioned in the real
historical arena how it was for example
the schoolhouse in the novel and the bad
tragedy that catapults in into this this
ascent into politics and path determined
almost by the way in which that bad
thing happened or his run which was
unsuccessful but in Murat up his energy
and his commitment to go on and then
become governor the next four years
later than election and you get ready to
do that so that energy that dedication
is unleashed by bad things
similarly the great floods I mentioned
in 27 which Unleashed Huey Long's career
the tragedy where New Orleans has
flooded and the federal government
doesn't do anything about it and people
are really angry and they react by going
for a politician who goes out and calls
the people who don't do things some
pretty bad names and uses that the
catapult his own career so that's a good
thing and all the things I mentioned
earlier in the real the the this massive
rise in efforts to provide literacy
Louisiana was the state with the highest
level of illiteracy in 1928 in the
nation no road so all these things of
hospitals this is on that was really
what you know the the Huey Long did
those things are good things even if
they came out of the flood he was taking
out only bad that struck people up so my
last thought would be to say well I
remember I said good things come out of
bad it's a an argument in the novelist's
I'm not sure exactly where the novelist
was down but but but I said maybe that
brings us up to today I think there's no
doubt that 9/11 opened up a dramatic new
space for the US government to operate
in the world in ways that would not have
been possible before our foreign aid was
just about the lowest of all the
industrialized countries as a share of
our our well-being our responsibility
was waning in a number of areas and here
was a chance now for us to be galvanized
and to do something good to put money
into aids put money into a Development
Assistance maybe even encourage
democracy in ways that we hadn't
previously a number of good things that
could happen try and undermine the
theses by which people would be drawn to
terrorism but you can ask yourself well
maybe the space was made there maybe the
political motivation does occur was the
flood of 27 or 9/11 or Katrina get back
right to the ground on which the novel
rest in a practical sense what did we
learn in the last nine months there in
terms of there's a shock not only to
Louisiana but to the nation there was a
demand that something be done and you
know Calvin Coolidge kind of ignored the
1927 flood and the Army Corps of
Engineers didn't do very much and get a
sense and even in Congress right now I
think there's a withdraw of efforts to
do things that respond to the needs of
people who have been wiped out and yet
still owned a mortgage they don't know
the house does its god those are the
poor people we know it was the poorest
wards so I think the kind of argument
about populism and motivation could
speak to us today if there were any
politicians around like Huey Long or
really stark who wanted to pick up that
framing of the situation and do
something with it and I've been kind of
puzzled why with these real
opportunities if you like the thesis
that good can come from bad that that
good is still for me rather problematic
so I maybe on that one well I've given
you my thoughts as lessons from the
novel not the novel as a very critical
in offer I'd now like to just commence
with seeing what your reactions thoughts
and questions are
the the the thesis that you say that
knowledge of the past is important for
being able to move forward to the future
seems to reflect the an idea that
knowledge of the four lessons that
you've described would also be helpful
to us as citizens as we go forward and
think about our own future together
I teach engineers at the University of
Virginia for the semester of a young
group of people who are learning about
politics and science and technology
areas and my impression of them is that
they they want to do good but that they
come from a background where politics is
messy and bad and evil and I wonder if
the lessons of the novel will make them
hope less as they try to do good as they
try to rebuild the dikes and to
reconstruct things that have been
damaged and that in a way this kind of
knowledge would actually harm the
capabilities of people who would be
otherwise with it might be paralyzed so
good well motivated capable people
Todd suggests that he's training
engineers would be made to cynical and
hence they would lose their energy and
their commitment and they become very
and they become a cynic learn withdraw
from positive action
maybe but yet see Willie's story was one
where he was exposed to the cynicism and
reacted by saying I'm gonna try all much
harder
so it was Herbert Hoover was an engineer
but probably never went through this
kind of trauma but you saw your
engineers if they were faced with
dealing with the corruption of politics
if they decided they wanted to get
involved as opposed to
stand back and be morally cure I would
say the novel really could speak to them
because if they look at me one of the
themes that I didn't say much about is
truth-seeking
and jacking again again says you have to
get the truth and that's really
important what's dealing with judge
Irwin or dealing with other issues he
says I'm just going after the truth you
gotta know the truth so I think they
have to know the truth if if if the Army
Corps of Engineers decided to under
spend in certain areas or if they built
shoddily or if the engineers at the
senior level we're really behaving in a
way that was more political than derived
from the sound principles on which they
were supposed to operate they have to
not say oh well it's all terrible we'll
withdraw from it I mean it's just
adjusting the introduction I I really do
believe that the you know we're here to
do something with our lives and that's
what I heard you to suggest them that's
the the challenges is to be cynical but
not excessively so
other questions
just thank you very much what's that I'm
not thank you very much for your your
talk I once thought I had in comparing
what was going on in the book and
compared to today is the use of the
politics of fear and this I don't think
necessarily came out and yet I would
think maybe it did exist but in a
different sort of guys I don't know if
you could speak to that too and one
other quick aside is is the racism and
sexism that is in the book - yeah well
those are two distinct the first was I
think thank you you say an excellent
excellent point one of the techniques by
which you're able to manipulate people
in politics is through fear artificial
fear you scare them you threaten them in
one form or another so it's not just the
rewards but it's the threat of in some
cases in Willie's case he's using the
police force in human long was because
you know thought of is on his road
toward fascism and some of his
pronouncements where he was for example
systematically taking over functions of
local government and getting rid of
people who opposed him earlier so he was
you know putting the fear of something
if not God the fear of Huey Long into
people in Louisiana and I think that
that's right I think the novel picks up
on on the manipulation of people by
threatening them by playing on their
fears
so I disagree with you there is a
strange absence in the novel the women
in the novel are I think compelling that
we never hear much of the maybe it's
because Jack's telling the story but
they all are rather passing on Sadie of
course is the most active among them but
they're only this the to my mind is this
the three loves of Willie Stark and to
some extent Jack Burton because Jack is
very much interested in Lucy as well and
they were he there was a that he does
treat remember Jack was after truth and
truth above all and at the very last
exchange he has with Lucy she asked him
a question
and he lies we were that and and that is
he said I did I live for me or did I lie
for her and he says I lied for her so I
think there's a kind of southern
nobility towards women I think there's a
sort of respect for women you know all
the allusions to the the sexual like the
ice skaters and Chicago and so on that
really has affairs with I you know it's
all done in a very non twenty-first
century style talking about these things
it's a very and so I'm not sure that
women are mistreated but they are
certainly not the center piece because
they aren't in politics except in this
supportive role of wife or a possible
mate for a presidential campaign or as
the as I said to Karl Rove type you know
did the tough advisor who knows what
politics is about as she did uh but the
the poverty people there's a couple
exchanges where people were poor and
Willie seems to be you know
acknowledging them but there's only a
few scenes where you recognize that
there's an african-american or a negro
and in it's almost as if this is a novel
was all white and no black and yet we
know that the population Louisiana was
thirty thirty-five percent black we know
that the people who were really at the
poorest and who didn't vote and that's
the issue this is a novel about real
politics and they didn't vote very much
they didn't really matter with all the
Democratic primary and that was run by
people who were at the head of the
County organizations and who could
control the press and we were both
Willie in the brothel and in the real
world Huey Long starts their own efforts
to communicate directly through radio
and their own publications so I think in
a way the Negroes just aren't the
African American of the Negroes and
olives are just not relevant to the
politics of Louisiana man I don't think
the novelist is necessarily therefore a
racist or and over I mean he may be I
just don't know enough about his other
person
as a human being or as a an author of
the books but I think he just is
reflecting the error and when she's
writing than also the politics he's
writing about if to stand over here
though maybe someone else that's a
question because you can get in line I
think we don't want to have too much
downtime or I'm gonna first have to MIT
I haven't read the book but but I
actually have a personal history my
family's from Winfield Louisiana and
every time we go back home we have to
drive past the Huey Long Memorial and I
I guess my I had tons of questions and
but because I'm actually working on some
family history and there's a book about
Huey Long we were refers to my
great-grandfather as a balloon headed
[ __ ] now that X is the black community
is actually a sense of pride because he
was a thorn in a lot of their sides
he actually mortgaged his house to start
the black school that my parents
actually went to and the it seems in
Louisiana now my dad was in the Navy so
I didn't really grow up there we always
went back home but I've been all over
but there's a kind of a moral ambiguity
in regards from the people side about
the politicians big I've always heard
these phrases oh well they're all crooks
but but the thing about it is they're
crooks but I'll get something done I
mean it's the only state that's elected
someone that was actually in jail so
there's there's this feeling of well we
all believe that they're crooks but you
know at least I get something done my
grandmother refers to you long and Earl
K long well they did right by black
people that's their right we respected
in the black community there's a huge
like I said there's huge that he's a big
guy but you walked it the Huey Long Park
and it's huge so my question is I that's
something that's always been believed in
in Louisiana or is it something nowadays
where people were starting to believe
all politicians well they're all crooks
but maybe they get something done from
whatever you saw with scams maybe start
with Nixon going left to here there's
definitely a different different police
system and you know what you look at the
range for Congress now they're all
really really low because they believe
they're fighting over asinine things
rather than getting something done so is
is it I'm gonna sort of answer my
question or not but yes it is
there's it seems the obvio a cynicism
with the last couple elections it seems
like they're willing a filibuster for
anything to just to get their way and is
that really I guess are they are we are
he seems like we're supposed to be
representing us but it seems like we're
kind of why people were tuning out
because they don't feel like they're
getting anything done and they're still
crooks versus was an interesting point
that somehow people who were corrupt and
crooks in politics took skimming money
off the top to build a machine or two
so we're also taking off the top of
public sector expenditures that were
redistributed they Huey Long went out
and I mentioned the story about the oil
company was getting he really put the
taxes on the wealthy in fact his
impeachment in 1929 in Louisiana which
failed just like in the novel was just
on that issue he was going to tax the
rich and redistribute and in that sense
the things he was doing were very much
going to help the people at the bottom
which were negro african-american
community but he was also a part of the
culture at that time Huey Long now in
which there was a stigma attached to for
example whites that fraternize in the
wrong way so actually he was
assassinated by the son of the judge
that was in a conflict with Huey Long
and what Huey Long was about to do was
to do a character assassination accusing
this judge of having brown genes so you
can see that you know that's outside the
novel but there I think that the novel
it does come out of a tradition in which
there's very much racial prejudice and
it feel like colors the whole politics
of the era now there is this also hero
notion that Huey Long really did get
things done and I got been there but I
understand the mind man in this whole
Clark in it is really quite fabulous but
he really he's deeply embedded in the
minds of many people in Louisiana and
particularly like your
parents and always I mean I think they
they don't see him as a racist or even
if he was tainted by it they were just I
think I think I would tend to agree with
you that there was a kind of willingness
Roosevelt a willingness to do a variety
of things that you would describe as
cynical and manipulative and so on in
order to accomplish a political good to
get something out there safety net for
the population and the depression for
example so where where if there's a
great disaster are we if we have an
intending overhang on Medicare immensely
Social Security where are people
thinking about how to solve that problem
of course that's more theoretical at the
moment but if we have a national
disaster where will they be people
willing to try and step up and repair
and reconstruct and do things to bring
some sense of justice in terms of
registration registration that's I don't
see at all there is a selfishness not
Willey of course was quite selfish at
one point he says you know Willie was
for Willie and Willie was lucky but but
he was so purely for himself that he
wasn't kind of evil whereas you know I
Jack Abraham how thoroughly we could
name others if we wanted to seem like
they're they're not only needed for
themselves of themselves and for
themselves in ways that that are also
not at all like the the kind of noble
self-interest that Willie was operating
under than allowable and maybe Huey Long
to I'm yeah I think that's
so what's different about the politics
today we're good hasn't come from evil
with 9/11 and Katrina well it's very
very easy to answer that because it
doesn't rely on my I can just take the
novel and put it we are confronted with
a lot of challenges and I think what's
what's happening today is that people
are defining them shallowly in the wrong
way
using stereotypes from or cold war
metaphors or solutions I mean perfectly
true that if you lower taxes or some
good things but that you if you take
that as a mantra and you don't even
think about stuff then the whole tax
structure becomes increasingly unjust
and and out of sync with reality and you
know so I I see a building up of
problems and I think 9/11 is really just
like a shock and we couldn't take a
great advantage as a way to move the
motivation of the American people or
even educate them to use the bully
pulpit of the presidency to say
something to the nation here's the way
it is folks people in the Middle East
hate us
people in Europe have now come to
heinous shallowly fortunately but Latin
America you hear a great speech by
anyone in either party coming out and
saying the United States is in some very
difficult situations now you know the
ship has not been struck by a torpedo or
it's not but there's some really rough
weather ahead and there's some rocky
coastline and there's some real problems
and in that metaphor we should be having
someone at the helm who's alert and
looking out and telling the truth and
trying to get information out I'm
selling of someone in a reception before
and they were saying one of the
interesting things about the current
ministrations they don't want to
research to get at the truth they want
to do research on how they can having
figured out what the truth is already
get people to adopt it or take advantage
of it or in treatment I think that's a
terribly wrong mindset whereas in a
novel and in real life we really have to
be more humble more seeking but also
that's um some reality out there I mean
there's just big
where I see is reality and what I hear
people talking about in sound bites or
way things are framed you know are you
for or against to see you for freedom
give for freedom how can you question
certain things if you want to and the
American economy has never been better
well you know the kind of claims that
somehow don't resonate with the
experiences that particularly people who
are not well-off so I just I found that
disjunction very frightening and I also
think that I don't hear voices clearly
articulating a way a way out
voices fear they're making a mistake if
I tell you today that we should get our
troops out of Iraq or we should reverse
the tax situation and we have a good
three quarters in the economy or you
know something goes really well for the
next nine months you're gonna have a lot
more Republican senators and you're
going to have a president that's been
verified and I if I'm a politician I'm
going to be in very difficult straits so
I don't want to make that mistake of
committing myself on an issue where I
could be used against me thanks
before I ask my question are there any
others my question is so ray what are we
going to read next year be careful how
you answer gosh expect that question you
should think it's things I read recently
I probably more like you've been to
movies like Syriana that have really
impressed me in their complexity I'm
thinking of literature and I gather
there was a novel or behind that which I
haven't read yeah we take a well
actually anyone want to help me out with
something that I can know about you know
I teach political science I've been very
little time to read novels and mostly
it's diversionary these days don't read
Clancy that's for sure but